this is just a short reminder and a
supplication also that Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala forgives the brother for his
shortcomings enters him into paradise
and makes him makes the questions that
he's going to be asked in the grave easy
for him as for each and every single
individual when they pass away then the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he mentioned that he will be
questioned about three things so the the
the angels will come to him and he'll be
asked about three things those three
things are who is your lord the one you
worship who is your messenger and what
is your
religion alhamdulillah from the mercy
and blessings of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala on the brother dearius is that
shortly before he passed away days
before he passed away or small weeks he
entered into Islam and his friends
mentioned to me that he was inquiring
about Islam for a long time and he was
on the fence about Islam for a long time
but once he heard certain things that
coincided and made sense to him then he
accepted the shahada and entered into
Islam my dear brothers and sisters and
for those who are not Muslim those
things that intrigued him and caused him
to enter into Islam were things such as
the fact that Muslims we worship Allah
and God only he's the only one that
deserves to be worshiped and we accept
and believe believe in all of the
prophets and Messengers whether it be
Jesus whether it be Muhammad whether it
be Moses Abraham and this is the only
religion that accepts each and every
single Prophet for who they are and that
Allah is the only one that he is worthy
of worship so this intrigued the brother
and caused him to accept the testimony
of Faith he
said he said that I bear witness that
God the one who created me and created
everything everybody is the only one
that should be worshiped no human being
no matter how righteous he is not
Muhammad not Jesus not anybody the only
one that deserves my reverence and my
worship is Allah because he created me
and he accepted this and he accepted
that the prophet Muhammad was the last
slave and messenger of Allah and this is
the only salvation this is the only key
to Paradise to accept all of the
prophets and all of the messengers and
Allah gave him that gift Allah
guaranteed for him to accept that
shahada that day that testimony of faith
and we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he enters into paradise and I am
100% sure that if dearius was alive
right right now that he would want each
and every single non-muslim from his
family and his friends to also accept
that he would want all of them to
believe that God is the only one that
deserves to be worshiped and that
Muhammad is his last messenger and to
accept each and every prophet and not to
pick and choose so my advice advice is
the same advice that the brother dearis
would be giving you right now if you
were to be standing here which is to
accept that Allah is the only one to
deserving of worship the same way his
family his mother and his sister and his
loved ones accepted Islam while he was
still alive and after he passed away
just like his friends accepted Islam he
accepted Islam and his family accepted
Islam so if you truly love the brother
then I will ask you my dear brothers and
sisters to contemplate and to think
think the thing that he did was there
anything wrong with it him testifying
that Allah is the only one that should
be worshiped and my life should be only
for Allah and that Muhammad was his
messenger and as for those who are
Muslim then this is also a reminder for
them that we don't know when we're going
to pass away we don't know when our time
is going to be that we're going to be
here and the rest of us are going to be
praying over us it could be tomorrow it
could be after a week it could be after
a month it could be years
we don't know when that time is going to
come but how we live our lives and the
choices that we make is what's going to
determine how our afterlife is going to
be so if you're in a situation where
you're making the wrong decisions you're
taking the wrong path then turn to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala because you don't
know when your time is going to be
you're not guaranteed tomorrow so
whatever it is that you're struggling
with that Allah is not happy with let
today be your reminder the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
said
he said increase in the remembrance of
the thing that's going to destroy your
desires when you want to go and do
something Haram when you want to go and
do something evil if you remember that
you're going to have to be here one day
it will stop you from going to do that
Haram and following your desires so my
dear brothers we ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala that he shows mercy and that
Allah subhana waa he makes it easy for
our brother to be questioned and that he
answers those questions with ease and
Allah subhah waala pardons him for the
few sins or whatever sins he may have
even done in those 27 days that Ed of
itself when a person enters into Islam
all of their previous sins are wiped
whatever it may be that they've done all
of their sins are forgiven so my dear
brothers and sisters take the same steps
that the brother took